there's this statue of a head that's in  the Sands of Egypt bigger than this  whole Road it's just the head it's worn  out and then in scripted along the  forehead it says here lies crazy name  who owned everything that the eye could  see the immortal so-and-so the only  thing that was left was a worn out  statue head that no one knew who he was  and it was five thousand years old if  that guy who ruled the known world to  him wealth probably mattered right but  does it matter no probably not I've  relieved a lot of the pressure in my  life so that I could make better  decisions by zooming way out and  thinking ten thousand years from now  will this matter and if the answer is no  does it matter to me and then if I can  make the decision of like good or bad  based on my new context that I created  then I can live a life a lot easier